let's get a new tape going all right
Richard here's what we're gonna do we
need a voice exemplar I want you to say
into this phone there's a bomb in
Centennial Park you have 30 minutes
Richard your national hero now thank you
sir
but I was doing my job
you've always looked at the guy who
found the bomb just like you always look
at a guy found the body jewel fits the
profile of the lone bomber a frustrated
white man who is a police wannabe who
seeks to become a hero we're running it
you're a suspect you don't talk I talk
safe Auto tone this might be the only
way to clear your name I want you to say
there's a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes stop trying to be the
best friend I was raised to respect
authority Authority is looking to eat
you alive there's a bomb in Centennial
Park we have 30 minutes I'm sorry what
his accusers are two of the most
powerful forces in the world the United
States government and the media I do
want to help you out law enforcement too
there is a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes he do it Richard Jewell
is an innocent man he's a hero there's a
bomb in Centennial Park you have 30
minutes
one more times a little louder
I report the facts you've ruined this
man's life
there is a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes to a couple rooms
son saved people's lives
[Music]
there is a bomb in centennial
you have 30 minutes
in Centennial Park here in 30 minutes
I don't how to protect you
like your client is guilty as hell they
want a fry you
you're going to start fighting back
[Music]
you